paid with someone over several leads and
I'm a property investor I've been
investing name property for 12 years and
we're about to enter a new decade and
things are about to change and in this
video I want to tell you what I'm gonna
do differently in property the things
I've really learned over 2019 it's
honestly been a roller coaster of a year
I bought 29 houses in 2019 and some big
deals a lot of small bills and I think
the biggest thing that I learned in 2019
is that it takes just as much energy and
effort to buy a suite 100,000 pound
house as it does to buy a big 3 million
pound house a big deal and a small deal
take the same amount of energy and you
make a lot more money on big deals now I
teach property ok I wouldn't property
investors crash course I do financial
freedom challenges and I think that I've
always kind of been doing the same thing
you know buying HMOs buying little
single that doing these deals I've been
in the same thing and now I just looking
at my last year or two I've made so much
more money on the big deals and it's
been so much less hassle like the castle
I bought castle and the castle last year
that we bought I'll become a millionaire
just off of buying the castle the land
that we bought with I'm building six
houses on a pizza landed linka I'll make
four hundred thousand pounds profit on
that haven't done anything it's been so
and then other property deals I've been
like banging my head off a brick wall
spending so much time on them just to
make 20 grand so I think what I'm gonna
do is is is 20 20 I'm just gonna focus a
little bit more big deals I might I
might doing a small deal time I might do
the small deals just document than just
a blog thumb you know some doing little
doing ventures and trying to help people
because I think when you start when
you're starting out you're always gonna
make a mistake when you start now I just
put your first deals the hardest you're
better to make them a stake on a small
deal than on a big deal but when you've
been in the game for a long time like I
have now I've got absolutely fantastic
connections with people I've got the
best power teams I'm now in central
London so I've got the best list is the
best accountants best mortgage brokers
I've got a great reputation so if people
come to me with deals people come to me
I need to just focus a bit more on the
big deals and in the same ways how I set
goals here's how I set goals at the
start of any year just bother talking
personal goals I'm talking everything
most people have like millions of things
on their to-do list and today I've got
to do these things and I've got tomorrow
I'm gonna do these things that all just
open everything to do this I don't do
that with me I write down just two or
three big things that if I achieved that
year I'd be like really happy and now
just focus solely on those big things so
2020 I just wanted to deals I want to
make a million pounds of one of the
deals and I want to I want a big deal
with a million pounds and then want a
big deal they'll make me three million
pounds that's it if I can get two big
deals next year
now I'm sure I'm gonna do loads more
deals but the cage is those two big
deals so and another thing is this I
kind of feel like I got a bit lazy the
last few years in terms of I was buying
houses
I got one of these little houses for
cash just because I couldn't be bothered
to fill out the paperwork because I was
just thinking oh man they're like 60
grand houses I can't be bothered to
apply for a mortgage so now I've got all
these little houses that I own I own
outright and I'm gonna now refinance
them because how I became successful in
the first place is a bit like you know
you get a big thing of toothpaste and at
first you're like yeah you know a lot of
toothpaste on you but then when you have
just a little bit you suddenly become a
bit more you become a bit smarter with
the toothpaste you know you put a little
bit on and you make it in the same way I
feel like want to start that my property
journey I was I didn't have much money I
didn't have much money at all so I was
kind of like I've got to be really smart
I got to be really careful with a little
bit that I've got well I've got no money
I've just borrowed 20 grand off my
grandma I need to make this I need to
put this to town I feel like because my
property business is done so well I kind
of got a bit lazy recently happy I've
had more we just paid off I've just been
handing people money hand-over-fist I've
been just saying you know you want to do
a deal here you go I set up almost I
didn't actually licensed the company
because I didn't need to but I was given
I gave over a million pounds last year
just in checks to people and you sell
just give me a guaranteed return and
then that give me that give me like 15
16 percent guaranteed return but then
they don't make millions and I think you
won't I know how to do that I should be
I should be leveraging off of my
knowledge and off of my brand and this
instead of saying oh man I've got money
I just give them money how and people
can give me a fixed return and then they
go make millions I should be saying I
know how to do that and I've got the
network actually and I think this just
walk right cardones when I make rent
card out and we spent some time together
in Miami last year I thought why is
grand car down almost a billionaire when
just a millionaire and what black card
Allen does he's Grant Cardone he's not
just content he's not just content with
with a little bit like at this point in
my life now I'm 20 I I could just say
I'm just gonna retire now you know I'm
28
I've got lots of houses I mean just the
castle alone the castles going to have 6
million on the end value I could just
rent it and I haven't got a mortgage on
that at the moment I mean every finance
it'll sell it believe me
but I could just rent that castle out
and live off of just just that one
property so I think now moving into a
new decade it's decision time it's
decision time the thing I've been
grappling with there over the disaster
areas am I now gonna start just paying
off mortgages settling down winding down
have kids I've got couple kids but be at
home travel and just worn down and be a
bit more safe oh and I'm gonna have that
same hunger I mean I've been doing some
work with some really cool people I mean
Anton joshua one of the things is is
stay hungry stay hungry and i felt like
the last year I felt like I've got some
cool deals they're not I've been doing
lots of big deals but I think I need to
act like I've just got a little bit in
the toothpaste again so I need is I need
I need to be more hungry and and and if
I want to be ultimately if I want to
change the world you can only change the
world but being the best you you can be
and staying hungry and I think now 2020
I want to do two really big deals really
big deals that scare me and I'm gonna
stop robbing stop raising finance I can
manage I've got like there's a hundred
fifteen thousand people currently as we
recorded that'll subscribe to this
channel I get thousands and thousands of
people coming to my events come into my
property courses and I love them I sent
I don't really want to do small bills I
don't really want to even gave the
property I just want to invest so
actually I've got the knowledge to do
doodlee big deals and to invest and I've
got the skills lots of power
the people rather than just investing my
own money
and rather than paying off mortgages and
just giving money to people I actually
think I should be saying to people hey
you can invest and maybe the other
person on the other end of the of the
spectrum and scale up massive so I think
I think 2020 for me is gonna be year of
just playing playing really big going
really hard and not being cog not being
comfortable not scaring back not playing
it safe because I don't think I don't
have to play it safe because I know the
game and when you when you've got the
knowledge then suddenly you can have the
confidence so and I've worked out
recently people say you know I want to I
want to die debt-free I don't want to
die debt-free I want to die with so much
debt because people are so scared of
debt but actually as long as as long as
you're using debt to serve you and just
scale up so I am NOT gonna be paying off
my mortgages in 2020 I'm gonna be
getting more debt I'm gonna be but I'm
also gonna be massively growing my my
wealth so this this this decade is watch
watch it you're here to here for Sunday
rich list I'm coming for you
Samuel Leeds billionaire in the making
it's happening continue to impact more
people massively and I'm excited I'm
excited and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna get uncomfortable again I've been
too comfortable in the property I've
been too comfortable in the property
industry buying all these little hundred
grand houses and also it pave is pride
and ego as well because I'm being really
blendable here but I kind of them I walk
if you'd have asked me a year ago I was
thinking I wonder I want to own more
houses than anyone owns in the UK but
actually that's really done because
owning lots of houses is not it's not
it's not the important thing the
important thing is helping lots of
people and making lots of money and a
lot of these people that have I don't
want to own loads and loads of houses
I've got lots of houses now I just want
to make a lot of money so a lot of my
house is now I'm actually selling
because I'm selling and I'm putting into
bigger deals so it's a different
spectrum it's a different headspace
I've also over the last year I've been
I've been
I didn't used to do if you'd have asked
me a year or two ago about saving money
and tax I didn't really understand any
of that stuff I mean I should just buy
all of my properties in my individual
name I know they changed the rules in
2016 and they said that the you can't
claim your interest payments is tax
deductible and then I'm just what I in
that case knows just paying off
mortgages just be really lazy 2019 I got
really smart
I studied tax laws I studied business
structures and and before I did just but
I just said I doesn't do that kind of
stuff doesn't matter or I have just said
oh I'm not really great when it comes to
tax on a really good moneymaker but tax
now I'm thinking smart I'm thinking big
and creating structures where I can you
know my great great grandkids might ever
have to worry about money ever again so
big year big decade and I'm also gonna
keep training because I'm people say to
me Savi if you're making so much money
in property then what do you teach
people just a dumb question I mean
number want to enjoy it but number two I
get famous off doing this stuff you know
it's it's more financial freedom
challenges am i running my crash course
is free who runs crash courses who who
do actually being there doing it got the
t-shirt who's making you know millions
in property runs free property training
courses and teaches people how to do it
for free like no one I don't know
anybody that does that not the extent we
do but in doing that stuff what happens
is people
everyone knows who I am so now I look
into an estate agents and then they're
who I am
you know I walk into I walk into a
property solicitors more firm or
wherever I'm going into then they know
who I am and the power of that I used to
say it's not just it's not what you know
it's who you know now I think it's both
it's what you know and who you know but
more powerfully it's who knows you so
that's one reason why I trained and we
have a training business but you know so
with some of our training programs we
have advanced programs and things but I
don't I don't give you a salary from
that you know for me I'm um I think that
you can you can't make cash flow
training but the real wealth is in
property and real estate and that's what
I learned from Grant Cardone Grant
Cardone has got a massive training
business but he makes his money and
really
they but he uses his brand and healing
widgets his network and people but who
know him from his tactic to help blow up
his real-estate business
so yeah that's kind of what's happening
this decade 2020 if you've got any
questions about this man huh I'm an open
book you know everything to public so
just comment ask me any questions you
want below if you enjoyed the video
please smash that like button and if you
haven't subscribed subscribe because I'm
going to be documenting stuff as well
some of these big deals
we've got ex hospital we got an ex
Hospital NHS that closed it's closed
down I've just got my guys at the moment
out they're going to be quoting to turn
that into luxury apartments it's in the
millions but we could we could make we
could make a lot of money on that I've
also got a fault I've hired a full-time
property director so he's named Ben
who's actually my wife's brother and
he's got 16 years in construction he's a
chartered surveyor and applying him he's
he's got a six-figure salary just help
find me big deals that's how much money
I'm making on big deals in the moment to
make on big deals
he's on a six-figure salary he gets a
property share and everything as well
and you know I've got a great team I've
got a great team I'm set up for serious
growth now and I also really enjoy boys
and people so I've had some very very
wealthy people high net worth
individuals famous people celebrities
athletes footballers that have been
coming into the office and we've been
talking have been I've been giving them
some counsel
giving us some investment advice but
also there's always opportunities to
joint venture with people as well so
yeah you heard it here first the Empire
is going below this decade thanks so
much see this time if you want to see
what I bought in 2019 2019 I mean that's
some cool stuff bubble in 2019 I give
all the figures you can watch it check
that video out right here if you wanted
to go to the property investors crash
course and if you're thinking oh my gosh
man I just want to get my first deal and
you just want to get started in property
or you want to learn how to be smart
come on to the property investors brush
goes right here not so please don't
forget to subscribe over here thanks so
much I'll see you next time